[موسيقى]
سنقدم في وقت لاحق اليوم حزمة من
العقوبات الجماعية والموجهة
للقادة الأوروبيين للحصول على موافقتهم ، حيث
يتم التنسيق بشكل وثيق مع
شركائنا وحلفائنا
الولايات المتحدة وكندا والمملكة المتحدة والنرويج ، ولكن
أيضًا على سبيل المثال اليابان وأستراليا
ستشمل هذه الحزمة
العقوبات المالية التي
تحد بشدة من وصول روسيا إلى
أسواق رأس المال
هذه العقوبات سيكون لها تأثير كبير
على الاقتصاد الروسي بالفعل واجه
ضغوطا مكثفة في الأسابيع الأخيرة
وهذه الضغوط سوف تتراكم الآن
هذه العقوبات ستعمل على قمع النمو الاقتصادي لروسيا
زيادة تكاليف الاقتراض رفع
التضخم وتكثيف رأس المال  وتدفق
وتدفق أساسها الصناعي تدريجياً إلى
[موسيقى]
لك